it's unbelievable how our childhood no
matter what we do how much we work on it
yeah it it just there's parts of it that
you just you you have let me tell you
your little kid is running the show
so the more you can
um
mine
everything that you were taught or
everything that was modeled to you in
front of you
from zero to eight years old
you will see every wall that you're
hitting as an adult
do you know the our brains
from the way we see ourselves
see ourselves in the world and how we
see the world looking at us totally in
place by eight years old
and this hits me home you have no idea
how much Ryan you know I mean it's I
always talk about the developmental
stages
from that that time period like I I
would say I would say kind of like
around it was six seven eight nine ten
yeah that that time period because what
happens is
true or false based in reality or not
you create your belief systems
and then from those belief systems
because as you believe it's delivered to
you
from those belief systems we create our
life and then we go well yeah but that's
the way life is that's the reality of my
life and it's the reality of Our Lives
because we believed those things that
were instilled in us before we had
reasoning
to work through them you're saying
in my interpretation
this is how my mind works
you're saying that as a child when I I
never felt I was loved ever I just
didn't I didn't feel that from my
parents they never told me I love you
I'm proud of you I'm you know all I just
never heard that I never
um
it was just I I didn't I never felt that
so I see in my life today it's hard to
allow people to love me
because I think no no no it's not that
they don't love it hold on okay well you
can't
feel anybody's love if you don't love
yourself I guess that's it you and we're
never taught to love ourselves
none of us are we we're taught that it's
braggadocious and it's you know God's
Not Gonna Love us if we're too full of
ourselves and people will judge us if we
think we're awesome
and so we're we're taught to put
ourselves down and so our little child
within us now is going I'm going to keep
you safe don't get too big I'm good
that's my job I'm going to keep you safe
and it's our job
as it's our job to be the parents of our
little child now and retrain them into a
a greater truth of how awesome and
loved and loving we are yes but but it's
very difficult when the people who
created you
you don't feel like you're worthy or
you're you're good enough or yes but it
is it is a hard thing and I've worked
something to them anymore that's true
that's true and that's as long as you
keep bringing them into the equation you
will never move on
yeah they look according to my channel
we pick our parents
I've heard that before
and we pick our parents to learn in most
cases what we don't want and what we
want to recreate in our lives
so they taught you
I don't feel loved
so that you could choose now in this
moment
I choose to love myself
so you know how much you love that dog
oh God when I walked in okay so just
feel that in your heart just feel how
much you love little blends
it's funny because it makes me like oh
like right when you said that it kind of
brings up like motions yeah yeah to give
that to yourself
see it really is easy